well I'm still optimistic but we haven't
got an offer that we can consider the
companies came up with a package
recently that we put to our members in a
mass consultation all around the country
and they found that the conditions
attach that very modest offer poor offer
really and not acceptable so there's a
debate going on between us and the
companies about what what they should do
next they've got to get a mandate from
the government we're expecting to meet
with them early next week possibly
Tuesday
to discuss the next steps but they've
really got to put some new money on the
table and they've got to take away these
these conditions that our members find
unacceptable and hopefully if we can do
that through constructive conversation
we can put a package to our people for
them to considering a vote but at the
moment it's just not there so it's the
money and it's the conditions just make
you know this has been running on for as
you as you are known as passengers know
for for um a good few months now what
are those conditions that your members
cannot accept
well the companies have stated to me
across the table they're going to close
every ticket office in Britain they're
going to introduce new contracts of
employment that will lower the wages not
increase them of new new starters in our
industry
they want to lower the wages of guards
they want to bring driver only operation
across the network as a principal so
that in the future
there will be no second person on train
even in the city trains that are
operating out of Houston here
they they want to dilute the sick pay
they want the dilute our holiday pay
they want to
make Sunday work in mandatory in areas
where it's never been mandatory so
people get no choices I think there are
18 items
of conditionality on this offer and the
offer itself is below half the rate of
inflation over the two years that this
dispute has been in in 22 and 23
and of course we haven't had a pay rise
in this industry for three years so if
you stack all that up it's a very poor
offer compared to the problems that our
members are facing the cost of living
crisis and all the rest of it but what
is really at the Forefront of our
members thinking is the conditions of
employment and the benefits that we get
from our employment are being diluted as
they have been for so many workers in
Britain many of whom are on a casual
basis uh on zero hours and all the rest
of it where other people have gone and
we're not going to tolerate that we need
good benefits we need proper agreements
and we don't want these conditions
imposed upon us we want an agreement on
the future of the Railway
yeah we don't have loads of time do you
want to get a few more questions to you
I mean you get any sense that with the
fact that nurses unions and unions
representing paramedics are asking their
members to accept their payoffer and
teachers are in talks here in the junior
doctors want to have talks as well any
sense of that's going to affect your
negotiating positions they're pressure
telling now for you guys to try and say
settle an agreement
well the pressure on us is from our
members our members need a deal that
they can accept what the difference
between our negotiations and everybody
else's it seems so if you take the fire
service teachers nurses doctors there
are no conditions this is new money
that's been introduced the the back pay
elements that they've put in last week
and the future payments there are no
conditions they're not saying to nurses
you've got to work different shifts
they're not saying to doctors you've got
to take less sick pay or lower pensions
in fact they're boosting doctors
pensions it seems from the headlines
I've seen they're saying to us in the
railway Railway pension scheme that
they're going to increase the
contributions and lower the benefits so
we call it strings attached it's the
strings that are attached to this deal
that really concern our people we're
realistic about what we can achieve on
money but nobody else seems to have
these conditions imposed upon them and
equally nobody else is working for
companies in the public sector that are
making vast profits since the pandemic
these companies have made 400 million
pounds of profit they're going to make a
over 118 million pounds this year and
they're paying their directors vast
amounts of money millions of pounds
being paid in individual salaries and
one of the directors had their salary
increased by 275 last year so that's not
acceptable we've got to get a bit of
fairness in this system and and make you
mentioned you've got pressure for new
members what about pressure from the the
public I mean you said this week that
when strike action's not on many of
these um train operating companies can't
run the railways properly anywhere then
you add further pressure to that when
there is Strike action and what's the
public meant to do
well we're sorry for the inconvenience
of the public but what the public are
caught in a system that is completely
incompetent the man the companies that
are extracting these profits from the
passengers and from the taxpayer
and care about whether there is a good
level of service because they are being
paid on strike days they were paid all
through the pandemic they are
indemnified from any loss in this
dispute by a government that's prepared
to subsidize an attack on the rmt and on
my members to some ideological reason
and that is so that they drive down
working conditions and teach the rest of
the working class A lesson and we're not
going to accept that lesson from a
government of billionaires and oligarchs
so what we're going to do is stand by
the conditions and the agreements that
we've made the contracts that we've made
and we hope that other workers in
Britain will sympathize with that we get
vast amounts of support as I travel
about the network on non-strike days
people come up to me and shake my hands
they they congratulate our members for
this steadfast resolve and they come up
to us on our picket lines which are all
around the country today and say keep
going until you get the result you need
you are fighting on and of course it's
worth noting as well that the strike
action the rmt had with network rail has
been paused by you negotiate there what
was on the offer there with network Rel
what did you manage to get through with
those guys that you can't resolve with
the train operating companies
well they've added money to the deal the
two deals were were very similar up
until a few weeks ago and network rail
have added extra money our members will
get extra earnings in network Rail and
it's not available in this deal from the
train operating companies they've also
said that the the payoffer is not
conditional on us accepting the changes
that they want to bring in we'll deal
with those changes separately through
the machinery and through consultation
and through the safety regulator that
we've got but the network rail deal is
not conditional as on accepting these
changes that they're saying in the train
operating companies have to be adopted
so there is a way forward that all of
the industry knows what needs to be done
the chief Executives that we deal with
but it's the government the people in
Whitehall that are stopping a deal being
done I think they're going to wait for
everybody else to be settled until they
deal with the rmt that's the way they
conduct themselves it's come from Grant
straps and Rishi sunak and before then
Boris Johnson they see the rmt as some
kind of Target we're prepared to take
that on we think we we've galvanized a
lot of change and a lot of change
fair enough the public will suffer while
you take that off people are suffering
what our people are suffering they lose
their wages the government is imposing
this dispute on the people and on the
passengers the government could settle
it tomorrow if they wish to they're
using the passengers and our members as
victims in the crossfire but their
ideological dispute with trade unions
and the anti-trade Union laws that they
want to bring in the suppression of
freedoms and all the rest of it all
right Mick Lynch General Secretary of
the rmt uh you're in talks of the
training companies on Tuesday you say
and thank you for your time this morning